imaginons que j'ai 100 pièces et que
j'ai une augmentation de 2 % suivie
d'une diminution de 1%
est ce que veut avoir une augmentation
de 1% au final ce que l'on peut ajouter
des pourcentages bien pour avoir une
intuition de ce qui se passe
une chose que j'aime faire et que des
scientifiques en général aiment faire
cesser de regarder ce qui se passe dans
des cas extrêmes au lieu d'avoir 2 % et
1 %
qu'est ce qui se passe si j'ai 200 %
d'augmentation suivi de 100 % de
diminution
si j'ai 200 % d'amélioration ça veut
dire que je vais avoir deux fois plus
que ce que j'ai déjà
en plus qu'est donc si j'avais sans
pièce ça va me faire sans pièces plus
deux fois 100 pièces qui va faire un
total de 300 pièces
maintenant si une diminution de 100 %
c'est à dire que je vais enlever 100 %
de ce que j'ai et enlever 100 % de ce
que j'ai bas ça veut dire qu'il me
restera plus rien donc on voit que
l'augmentation de 200 % suivie d'une
diminution de 100 %
ça fait au final une diminution de 100 %
c'est bizarre en fait on n'a pas une
addition des pourcentages en tout cas
dans ce contexte là mais si maintenant
je passe à une augmentation de 20 %
suivie d'une diminution de 10% et que je
fais le calcul ça veut ajouter deux
colonnes et me retirer une et donc à la
fin j'aurais 108 pièces donc une
augmentation de 8 % donc 20%
d'augmentation suivi de 10% d'une
diminution
ça fait 8 % d'augmentation cours n'est
pas loin du 10 % ça s'additionne pas
mais c'est quand même beaucoup plus
juste dans ce cas de dire que ça
s'additionne que dans le cas précédent
mais passons à la question initiale cet
exercice qui correspond à une
augmentation de 2 % suivie d'une
diminution de 1% alors je vais vous
laisser faire les détails des calculs
chez vous et je vais juste vous donner
le résultat ça fait une augmentation de
0.98 % autant dire que l'as quasiment 1%
on a quasiment une vraie addition luxe
assez bizarre et assez 1
reid ans et qui se passe l'impression
que quand les pourcentages sont très
faibles
on peut vraiment quasiment les
additionner alors que dès qu'ils sont un
peu grand ou ne peut plus les
additionner le phénomène mathématiques
qui est derrière tout ça c'est la magie
de ce qu'on appelle les développements
limitée qui sont une source de
simplification de calcul absolument
monstrueuse et qui permet de bien mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe dans notre
univers par exemple si le suit dans un
train qui va 50 km/ha récit je lance une
balle qui va à 50 km heure par rapport à
moi dans le train quelqu'un qui serait
en dehors du train a priori verrait la
balle allait à 58,50 est égal à 100
km/heure priori les vitesses
s'additionnent en physique digne et
honnête physique classique que vous avez
appris au lycée les vitesses en effet
s'additionnent aux biens mais cette
addition des vitesses est en fait fausse
un peu comme l'addition des pourcentages
et n'est valide que pour des vitesses
très faible faible par rapport à la
vitesse de la lumière
einstein découvre à un peu butin en 1905
que les vitesses ne s'additionne en
faites pas enfin elle ne s'additionnent
pas si elles sont proches de la vitesse
de la lumière
mais si les vitesses sont des vitesses
très loin de l'été et la lumière est en
fait dans notre vie quotidienne on a les
vitesses chaque fois qu'ils sont très
très petit par rapport à vitesse de la
lumière
l'un des vitesses s'additionnent presque
un peu comme des pourcentages qui sont
assez loin du 100 % s'ils sont plutôt de
l'ordre de 1% voire de 1 pour 1000
s'additionnent assez bien alors tout ce
que je viens de raconter après ça pas
l'air très mathématique pas très rigolo
utiliser des mots comme son pop
quasiment additionner chose c'est pas
très mathématique a préféré pourtant il
ya une façon de formaliser tout ce qui
est assez important de comprendre je
pense correspond à dire que quand on
fait une addition de pourcentage ou de 8
aces et bien on fait l'addition mais il
restera toujours un terme qui correspond
à une erreur donc je vais revenir sur
l'addition des pourcentages pour pouvoir
livrer cette idée de développement
limité
en fait quand je dis que j'ai une
augmentation de
2 % ça veut dire que je vais multiplier
l'ensemble des biens que j'ai par un
plus x ou x et dans ce cas le 2%
donc si j'ai une augmentation suivi une
autre augmentation
la première étant de x 2e et andy y ça
correspond à dire que je vais multiplier
d'abord par un pays x ensuite par un
plus y ok maintenant quand je développe
ce produit j'ai obtient un plus xy tu là
le pourcentage s'additionnent mais on
fait aussi une erreur qui correspond aux
thermes x x y
donc dans cette formule la partie
xmoussx correspond à la partie a dit il
dans son indica était quasiment juste la
raison pour laquelle est née que
quasiment juste c'est à cause de
l'erreur
le terme x x y ce que le terme x ou y
quand x et y sont très petit s'ils sont
de l'ordre de 1% par exemple est bien le
terme x ou y est beaucoup plus petit que
chacun des termes x et y
et du coup quand x et y sont très petit
l'erreur est très petit
devant la partie a dit il de cette
opération
c'est pour ça que lorsque x et direction
très petit il est raisonnable de dire
que l'erreur est négligeable et que l'on
peut additionner les pourcentages cette
astuce est incroyablement utile dans
toutes les sciences sont en économie en
biologie et en chimie ou en physique
l'étude et développement limité ou
montre que ce qu'on étudie va avoir une
tendance linéaire circoncis on étudie
deux éléments qui s'influencent par
exemple la consommation de tabac et la
probabilité d'avoir un cancer
si on regarde localement c'est hélas si
on regarde pour des petites variations
de la consommation de tabac et
l'influencé que ça à voir
vet linéaire plus généralement quand on
étudie n'importe quelle relation entre a
et b et ben si on regarde uniquement
localement on va s'attendre à observer
des relation linéaire d'après la théorie
des développements limité j'espère que
vous avez aimé cet épisode la prochaine
fois on a parlé de la rotondité de la
terre et la question à quel
j'aimerais que vous réfléchissiez c'est
comment sait-on que la terre est ronde
d'ici là j'espère que vous avez leaké
cette vidéo la partager et vous abonner
à la chaîne et j'espère que je vous
verrai la prochaine fois à quoi
ressemble un additionnel 4 bits en des
mineurs est bien à ceux ci en
mathématiques il existe des objets qui
sont plutôt additifs tandis que d'autres
sont plutôt des objets multiplicatif